action salut à tous bienvenue sur ma
page facebook de number one direction
chamonix c'est là où il ya les meilleurs
tels que fulham n'ont pas envie moi je
vous connais j'ai vu tous vos films
ce qu'il fout là nuit mon propre
c'est-à-dire avec des ensembles cas les
images non je l'avais pierrick l'aube
quand les amis dit-il piou piou piou
parce que tous les grands riders ont des
surnoms
je veux devenir une star gagner du fric
l'animateur télé me rappelle quelqu'un
je suis pas si con l'everest le couloir
en baisse
c'est le graal moi ce que je veux c'est
faire des premières fouilles des
premiers c'est pas pour ça qu'on descend
une pente tout le monde en rêve personne
n'y vas tu crois pas qu'ils aient une
raison non
màj le style
parce que ce qui est beau c'est
mouvement
ce qui est beau c'est l'harmonie du
mouvement avec la pente ce quoi toi
excuse moi j'ai regardé la fin on ne
regardait pas la peinture garder le vide
cet appareil
j'ai envie de 170 pas
ce qui avec lui se traduire
avec la vitesse
je veux d'italie
étude et en semaine
[Musique]
c'est vrai que c'est beau
je peux faire à sa fille tu m'emmerdes
[Musique]